Anthony going deep he's going to score  and one  [Applause]  that's four fouls on Turkish  and he is slow to get up he took the  hint right there as he tried to defend  that shot Melo had both his hands on the  ball  I made a solid move to the basket  nothing there on that play hard to tell  from that angle let's see if this  particular camera angle pass nothing I  didn't see it that's like this is in a  birdie contact and once again if it's a  three-point play for might have been  might have been that one above the  basket I thought I saw a little elbow  touch in there now what gets me here is  wise why the officials looking at this  blame and not the one we're on Iman the  crew chief no basket  flagrant foul two on Anthony you've  gotta be kidding me  he's out of the game wipe out the basket  and Anthony has been tossed I'm sorry  that's ridiculous  [Applause]  clearly  and imbalance right here  [Applause]